neue köpfe neue konzepte die spd will
eine grundlegende reform des
sozialstaats und als vier hinter sich
lassen
ein klick ein fake verbraucherschützer
warnen vor gefälschten online shops
besonders jetzt zur weihnachtszeit viele
feuer und viel rauch australiens
metropole sydney ist den dichten qualm
gehüllt im hinterland breiten sich die
brände weiter aus
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster und damit herzlich
willkommen bei den heute -nachrichten am
samstag sport gibt's ausführlich in
kürze von christin vor allem mit
wintersport zum spd-parteitag da haben
sich die sozialdemokraten heute für ein
neues sozialstaats konzept ausgesprochen
wesentliche punkte ein sogenanntes
bürgergeld soll die grundsicherung von
hartz 4 ablösen und jedem eine
gleichberechtigte teilhabe ermöglichen
den mindestlohn will die spd auf 12 eur
anheben und für jedes kind ein
kindergeld von mindestens 250 euro
schaffen
andreas huppert und las bohnsack eine
partei verabschiedet sich von einem teil
ihrer geschichte dem teil der die spd
seit über 15 jahren gespalten hat
zentrale punkte der agenda 2010 die
hartz4 sollen der vergangenheit
angehören
diese klarheit in der überwindung der
rezepte von vor 15 jahren die ist glaube
ich sehr stark zum ausdruck gekommen
aber mit der klaren ansage auch dass es
einen einen tragenden sozialstaat gibt
der sowohl die berücksichtigt die
solidarität brauchen als auch die die
solidarität zu geben bereit sein müsse
hartz4 soll zum bürgergeld umgebaut die
umstrittenen sanktionen entschärft
werden darin ist sich die partei einig
hat vier hatte seine zeit aber passt
eben nicht mehr in die heutige zeit und
den haben wir uns gestellt und wir gehen
jetzt einen neuen weg es sind ganz neues
denken von sozialstaat und ich bin froh
dass wir hier vorreiter sind faire löhne
bessere bildung chancen dazu das thema
kindergrundsicherung darin will die spd
künftig alle bisherigen staatlichen
familienleistungen bündeln es soll einen
basisbetrag in höhe von 250 euro geben
für jedes kind plus einen zusatzbetrag
in abhängigkeit vom einkommen der eltern
und vom alltags kennen
die spd baut am sozialstaat der zukunft
und will damit ihr profil schärfen spd
kann sich damit auch wieder sehr stark
als als soziale partei definieren und
wir werden mit diesen inhalten auch in
der regierungszeit bereits stark
operieren und die in diese inhalte auch
in den vordergrund stellen gewählt wurde
heute auch noch und zwar der
parteivorstand zwei prominente
mitglieder schafften es nicht berlins
regierender bürgermeister müller und
ralf stegner scheiterten mit ihren
bewerbungen und beide spd in berlin ist
matthias fornoff für uns matthias welche
botschaft hat dieser parteitag nun
ausgesendet alles harmonisch vereint
hinter der neuen doppelspitze
naja die spd hat hier so eine art
befreiungsschlag versucht das ist ja
auch verständlich nach bitteren
wahlniederlagen schlechten umfragewerten
und ständigem frust über die große
koalition in der tat das führungsduo
esken walter borjans das ist unfallfrei
installiert worden die eigentlich
gespalten und die verunsicherte partei
hat zusammengehalten
sie hat auch ihre ideen für den
sozialstaat von morgen verabschiedet und
damit ihren sozialdemokratischen
markenkern zukunftsfähig gemacht aus
hartz 4 wird ein deutlich milderes
bürgergeld und ihr langjähriges trauma
die agenda 2010
das lassen die sozialdemokraten hinter
sich bei all dem hat die spd links
geblinkt fährt aber geradeaus weiter als
co pilotin der groko ob die wähler das
verstehen wird sich zeigen
die große koalition jedenfalls scheint
ein stück stabiler zu sein als vor
diesem parteitag denn die spd revolution
dagegen die ist ausgefallen
danke für ihre einschätzung matthias
nach berlin
den ganzen parteitag der spd können sie
bei uns im live blog auf heute de
verfolgen auch mit reaktionen
dort haben wir außerdem die wichtigsten
entwicklungen und beschlüsse für sie
zusammengefasst
die cdu zeigt sich wenig angetan von
einigen beschlüssen des spd-parteitags
solén parteichefin kramp karrenbauer die
gestern geforderte nach
schärfung des klimapakets ab und sie ist
gegen ein abrücken von der schwarzen
null wie sie der bild am sonntag sagte
solange fördermittel etwa für schulen
nicht abgerufen würden mache es keinen
sinn neue schulden zu machen
nach großbritannien auch da sind die
sozialdemokraten geschwächt und
versuchen boden gut zu machen
knapp eine woche vor der parlamentswahl
gab es gestern abend für die opposition
eine weitere chance und zwar beim
letzten tv-duell zwischen
premierminister johnson und labour-chef
corbin in den umfragen führen johnsons
konservative bisher deutlich abgaben nun
doch noch punkten konnte live im
fernsehen ja sinn her
spannung und begeisterung wollten nicht
so recht aufkommen das ist den ganzen
wahlkampf immer schon so spärlichen
applaus für boris johnson und jeremy co
bin beim letzten rede duell der beiden
hauptkandidaten fürs premierminister amt
für viele briten stellen sie nichts
anderes als eine wahl zwischen dem
geringeren übel johnson liegt in den
umfragen deutlich vorn da schien es
ratsam die aussagen einfach zu halten
was er dann auch gleich mehrfach tat
wir müssen liefern kann stets punkten
wenn es um das kaputtgespart sozialwesen
geht vor allem den nationalen
gesundheitsdienst als er zum
premierminister ernannt wurde versprach
40 neue krankenhäuser dann waren es 20
jetzt sind es nur noch sechs der
premierminister scheint ein problem mit
zahlen zu haben johnson will bei einer
klaren mehrheit der exit bis zum 31
januar unter dach und fach bringen
corbijn plant mit brüssel neu zu
verhandeln und dieses abkommen dann in
einem zweiten referendum zur wahl zu
stellen neben der option in der eu zu
bleiben
johnson wirft seinem kontrahenten vor
einen schlingerkurs zu fahren
wir haben bisher noch nicht gehört wie
der deal aussehen sollte in der neu
verhandeln will und ob er ihn in einem
referendum dann auch wirklich
unterstützt
das zieht beim wähler glaubt man den
umfragen dann sind es vor allem klarheit
und dass alles bald vorüber ist was sich
die berechnet und wahlkampf gegen briten
wünschen in frankreich dritter
protesttag gegen die geplante
rentenreform
ermutigt vom generalstreik gegen neben
gewerkschaftern auch sogenannte gelb
westen auf die straße sie demonstrierten
wie hier in paris gegen die politik von
präsident makro die polizei setzte
mehrfach tränengas ein
viele reisende steckten fest weil züge
ausfielen
auch der verkehr zwischen frankreich und
deutschland war betroffen immer mehr
menschen in deutschland versorgen sich
an gemeinnützigen tafeln und die kommen
jetzt logistisch an ihre grenzen zu groß
der andrang so der bundesverband der
tafeln dieses jahr nutzten mehr als 1,6
millionen menschen das angebot an
kostenlose lebensmittel zukommen
das sind zehn prozent mehr als im
vergangenen jahr
besonders groß ist die nachfrage bei
älteren menschen
vorsicht falle nepper schlepper
bauernfänger so warnte das zdf erstmals
vor 55 jahren vor trickbetrügern heute
agieren die natürlich auch im internet
und in der vorweihnachtszeit haben sie
hochkonjunktur meist preisen sehe
getarnt als online-shop teure waren
billig an lassen sich das geld ins
ausland überweisen und verschwinden wie
man betrüger erkennt zeigt uns eine art
der regen hält die hamburger nicht ab
von der suche nach geschenken voll ist
die innenstadt wenn die zeit bis
weihnachten drängt manch einer bleibt
lieber zu hause und versucht online noch
ein schnäppchen zu machen führt sich
euro weniger für einen saugroboter den
sich dann jeder lauf wünscht sie
bestellt bezahlt und wartet vergeblich
dann dachte ich okay dann sucht jetzt
noch mal auf dem shop nach einer hotline
anruft bei der kundenhotline an und da
musste ich dann feststellen dass der
shop schon nicht mehr online ist und ich
dadurch auch keine telefone machen
sie ist nicht die einzige die auf medias
fuchs 24 reingefallen ist gut 150 euro
sind weg
auf einem konto im ausland
in der verbraucherzentrale häufen sich
derlei online betrugsfälle mehr als vier
millionen betroffene deutschlandweit
zählen die berater inzwischen sind die
fake shopbetreiber leider so
professionell dass auch wir mit
geschulten blick nicht auf den ersten
blick erkennen können ob es ein fake
shop ist oder eben nicht wichtig sei
daher spontankäufe zu vermeiden
stattdessen prüfen ob kontaktdaten
gütesiegel und rabatte realistisch sind
sichere zahlungswege von vorauskasse
wird eher abgeraten und bei
betrugsverdacht schnell reagieren und
zweifel dessen das geld weg sollte man
auf jeden fall die ganzen unterlagen die
man hat e-mails wie auch immer
zusammentragen und dann möglicherweise
auch eine strafanzeige erstatten und
dann jeder lauf hat anzeige erstattet
und sie will sich nun nicht mehr von
rabatten im netz sondern vom angebot der
innenstadt verführen lassen
überraschende wende in einem der
spektakulärsten kunstdiebstähle der ddr
tatort das museum von schloss
friedenstein in gotha
hier brechen die diebe im dezember 79 1
ihre beute fünf wertvolle gemälde wie
dieses porträt von frans hals fast 40
jahre fehlt von den meisterwerken jede
spur
bis die museumsstiftung ein angebot
erhält ein krimi mit happy end andreas
postel berichtet
schloss friedenstein in der nacht zum 14
dezember 1979 bestens vorbereitet
klettern der oder die täter mit
steigeisen an der dachrinne zehn meter
bis zur galerie der niederländischen
meister empor ein messgerät im inneren
registriert einen deutlichen
temperaturabfall verursacht durch die
eindringende winterkälte tatzeitpunkt
somit datiert auf 32 seitdem fehlten
fünf erstrangige werke der renaissance
und des barock darunter das
selbstbildnis mit sonnenblumen nach
anthonis van dyk landschaft mit bauern
wagen und kühn
von jan brueghel dem älteren und die
traurig schauender heilige katharina
gemalt von hans holbein
der wert der gestohlenen gemälde wurde
damals auf rund fünf millionen mark
geschätzt
im vergangenen jahr wurden sie dem
oberbürgermeister von gotha zum kauf
angeboten
das war schon ein moment der die knie
weich werden lässt der vielleicht auch
eine träne im augenwinkel drückt denn
ich persönlich habe es nicht für möglich
gehalten nach 40 jahren völliger
unkenntnis dass das gelingt nach
schwierigen verhandlungen wurden sie
tatsächlich in berlin übergeben stammen
angeblich aus einer erbschaft gegen zwei
tatverdächtige wird ermittelt aufgrund
dieses umstandes haben wir ein
ermittlungsverfahren eingeleitet wegen
des verdachts der versuchten erpressung
und wegen hehlerei
die ermittlungen laufen natürlich noch
auch die untersuchung der gemälde ist
noch nicht abgeschlossen sollten sie
tatsächlich echt sein wächst auch die
hoffnung den spektakulären kunstraub von
gotha nach 40 jahren doch noch
aufzuklären
eu-kommissionspräsident in ursula von
der leyen ist für ihre erste
außereuropäische dienstreise nach
äthiopien gereist
afrika sei ein partner auf augenhöhe
sagte sie bei ihrem treffen mit moussa
faki dem kommissionschef der
afrikanischen union für mehr sicherheit
und weniger ungeregelte migration sei
eine enge zusammenarbeit entscheidend im
osten australiens halten mehr als 100
buschfeuer einwohner und feuerwehren
seiten wochen in atem
rauchschwaden liegen inzwischen auch
über der millionenstadt sydney die
situation verschärft sich im bundesstaat
new south wales an vielen stellen
weil sich mehrere feuer vereinigt haben
verheerende schäden auch in den
nationalparks normen odenthal berichtet
in der hölle auf erden wird gekämpft auf
leben und tod
doch die kräfte die hier wütend sind
einfach nicht zu zähmen
die feuerwehr hält dagegen solange es
geht
und bis einer weg hier schreit im
letzten moment löst ein feuer und hinter
die alu rad schon das nächste wahnsinn
ein flammen wirbel und man bekommt eine
ahnung wie schnell alles geht wie
unaufhaltsam unkontrollierbar die
situation ist fliehen aufgeben oder
weiterkämpfen der grat zwischen mut und
leicht sind ist extrem schmal
der wind dreht die funken fliegen lösen
neue brände aus die feuer fressen sich
durchs land die lage ist düster die
aussichten erst recht wir gehen auf den
sommer zu und wir erleben dass die feuer
sich auf die gesamte küstenlinie
ausbreiten
sie rücken näher an dicht besiedelte
gebiete heran im süden in der mitte und
auch richtung witten
schon jetzt ist die metropole immer
wieder in rauch gehüllt ärzte warnen vor
erheblichen gesundheitsgefahren vielen
menschen fällt das atmen schwer
und wer weiß was noch auf sie zukommt an
vielen fronten also muss der kampf der
einsatzkräfte weiter gehen heute stürzt
ein helikopter im hitze strudel abt
pilot unverletzt lautet die einzig gute
nachricht des tages zum sport und einem
turbulenten bundesliga spielt ist die
heißer kampf um die spitze aber borussia
mönchengladbach hat es tatsächlich
geschafft und bleibt tabellenführer
nach einer überaus spannenden partie
gegen den fc bayern münchen dank eines
verwandelten foulelfmeters von ben
sebari in der nachspielzeit zum 2 2 1
gegen den rekordmeister
zuvor hatte matthias gelb rot gesehen
bei 363 2 1 gegen hoffenheim trifft timo
berner zweimal dortmund deklassiert
düsseldorf mit 15 0
freiburg wolfsburg 1 2 augsburg mainz 2
1 das abends spielt leverkusen schalke
ausführlich im aktuellen sportstudio
gestern frankfurt härter 22 morgen union
berlin köln und bremen paderborn also
unverändert an der tabellenspitze
gladbach einen punkt vor leipzig schalke
kann sich noch vor dortmund sieben
abgerutscht hinter freiburg die bayern
inzwischen sieben punkte rückstand als
sechster leverkusen könnte sogar auch
noch vorbeiziehen im keller tauschen
härter und düsseldorf die plätze
schlusslichter bleiben auf alle fälle
köln und paderborn und gewiss gut
gelaunt wird nachher leipzig trainer
julian nagelsmann zu gast im aktuellen
sportstudio seien nach dem sieg gegen
seinen alten verein aus hoffenheim
gelungener weltcup einstieg von
snowboard weltmeisterin selina jörg aus
sonthofen beim parallel-slalom in
russland musste sich nur im finale der
schweizerin julie zogg geschlagen geben
aber es gab noch mehr wintersport
highlight jacqueline lölling gewinnt den
weltcup auftakt im skeleton die
sauerländerin in beiden läufen die
schnellste in der eisrinne von lake
placid vor der österreicherin janine
flock weltmeisterin tina herrmann aus
königssee wird dritte erster podestplatz
für die dsv adler im dritten weltcup
springen karl geiger links springt in
nischni tagil russland zweimal 130 meter
weit platz zwei besser nur yuka sato 132
meter im zweiten sprung der erste
weltcupsieg für den japaner
die laufform stimmt bei den deutschen
kombinierern die ergebnisse auf platz
drei für fabian rießle der schwarzwälder
sprintet von platz elf aufs podium knapp
vor teamkollege vinzens geiger hier
links in einer eigenen liga unterwegs
ist weltmeister jan magnus lieber auch
beim heimspiel in lillehammer der
norweger dominiert auf der schanze und
in der loipe
sein vierter sieg im vierten
weltcup-rennen
nach nicht in der erfolgsspur die
deutschen biathleten schwierige
bedingungen beim weltcup in östersund
schweden philipp horn muss dreimal in
die strafrunde
das parkett mit erik lesser arnd peiffer
und benedikt doll läuft auf platz acht
das erste staffelrennen der saison
gewinnt norwegen berlin und hamburg sind
raus bei der diskussion um eine neue
bewerbung deutschlands für die
ausrichtung olympischer sommerspiele
2000 32 einziger interessent bleibt die
initiative rhein ruhr verkündete dsb
präsident alfons hörmann in frankfurt am
main auf der mitgliederversammlung
versicherte bundesinnenminister horst
seehofer volle unterstützung für ein
sportliches großereignis hierzulande
allerdings forderte er auch weniger
kommerz bei olympia und mehr
aufmerksamkeit für die athleten
tja genau so soll es ja auch sein und
jetzt tut es vorweihnachtlich er ist süß
und wiegt knapp 4000 kilo der dresdner
riesenstollen unter dem puderzucker
stecken eine dreiviertelmillion rosinen
und sultaninen und mehr als 200
kilogramm an der endstation der
historischen parade der altmarkt hier
ging es dem backwerk an den kragen für
sechs euro das pfund war man dabei der
erlös geht an einen guten zweck zum
wetter das soll stürmisch und regnerisch
werden wann und wo es sie erwischt das
weiß gleich gunther tiersch so viele von
uns das heute journal mit claus kleber
um 23 uhr 15
wir danken für ihre aufmerksamkeit
wünschen einen entspannten abend und
sind dann morgen wieder zur stelle punkt
19 uhr